the evolution of programming languages
have paved the way for new possibilities
in the world of software development
believe it or not according to the
historical Encyclopedia of programming
languages we have
8945 programming languages and Counting
it's a natural law that nothing lasts
forever likewise despite their
unparalleled caliber and contribution to
the I.T industry there are a few
languages going obsolete the
introduction of a few rookie programming
languages makes the current ones look
like their Valor is coming to an end
soon now the question arises which of
these programming languages are the ones
you should least focus on
we have created this video based on the
trends potential job opportunities
repositories programmer communities and
surveys on websites like stack Overflow
and many more
so you are already watching simply learn
and today we bring you the list of the
top 10 dying programming languages in
the year 2023. at number 10 we have
coffee script coffeescript is one of the
lightest languages ever designed
coffeescript a single threaded and
synchronous programming language had
fewer lines of code than JavaScript with
increased readability compared to its
predecessor coffeescript was adopted by
major companies like Dropbox GitHub and
many more to develop their browser site
code however the latest migration chose
JavaScript as a better alternative as of
January 2020 coffeescript was declared
Obsolete and is no more operational
at number nine we have Ruby with six
percent of the worldwide programmers
Community Ruby is in ninth place on our
list for today
Ruby is extensively used in building web
applications data processing Automation
and many more the most prominent of all
its applications is Ruby on Rails also
known as RoR it's highly believed that
Ruby still has a lot of potential but
it's considered obsolete based on its
competition
allies like python are comparatively
less verbose highly readable and offer
better code security than Ruby hence
slowly Ruby is also becoming obsolete if
not completely dead at number eight we
have VBA Visual Basic VBA was one of the
most extensively used programming
languages not only beginners but also
corporates also use the VBA the language
could build High Performance Tools to
extract data from various sources
companies like Microsoft arcgis AutoCAD
Coral draw and labor office used VBA to
manage their internal operations
Microsoft's VBA currently shares four
percent of the worldwide developer
Community despite being based on.net it
is no longer updated by Microsoft
indicating its obsolescence
at number seven we have Scala Scala was
a well-known language in the developers
Community for a really long period it is
one of the most powerful languages that
are based on Java with the potential to
process petabytes of Big Data it's not
because of performance but because of
the features which most developers are
unaware of yes migration to Scala from
java is a little difficult as it offers
a steeper learning curve also skull has
a smaller developer community of 2.9
worldwide making support scars
at number six we have Objective C
Objective C has already established a
firm foot in the world of application
development so much so that libraries it
supports are nearly impossible to
recreate with a new language Objective C
was originally used by Apple to develop
its applications for Apple devices but
due to its verbose nature complex syntax
and outdated libraries Apple made the
switch to Swift for the ease of code
readability and application development
with less than 2.5 percent of the
worldwide developer Community Objective
C is close to becoming an obsolete
programming language soon
at number five we have Pearl originally
developed for script manipulation Pearl
has turned out to be one of the go-to
languages for web development it is one
of the most efficient open source
languages for text manipulation despite
its Simplicity and efficiency Pearl
comes with a major drawback Pearl fails
to support portability because of cpan
modules programs run slowly and must be
interpreted each time any changes are
made
these drawbacks have resulted in the
drop of developers in Perl currently it
has less than 2.3 percent of developers
worldwide
at number four we have Haskell with
similar numbers a 2.2 percent share of
developers worldwide we have Haskell
earlier Microsoft and similar companies
depended on Haskell for their software
development lately Haskell has faced
issues like no proper IDE support
complex syntax and a steep learning
curve this forced developers to migrate
to better alternatives
also Haskell's major disadvantage is its
inability to support Android development
these are some of the significant
reasons to turn Haskell into a fading
programming language
now we come to our top three most
powerful yet obsolete languages at
number three we have Fortran
Fortran had laid foundations in various
domains for a decent period of 30 years
everything was handled using Fortran
from designing Bridges to airplanes and
Factory automation to data analysis
such a glorious language also turned
obsolete while facing the test of time
developers soon had to migrate from
Fortran due to a lack of dynamic memory
reliability and unsafe code prone to
cyber threats currently less than one
percent of developers worldwide are
working with Fortran at number two we
have erlang erlang escalated
telecommunications processes to new
heights for Ericsson apart from telecoms
erlang supported banking e-commerce
computer systems development and instant
messaging services
despite its capabilities to develop
almost everything in the tech industry
the Achilles heel of erlang was its
complex debugging procedures and
critical deployment issues this resulted
in the deterioration of the might of
erlang today a handful of developers
with less than one percent worldwide
operate in erlang that brings us to our
top programming language which is slowly
becoming obsolete at number one we have
COBOL cobal is one of the languages from
Mainframe computer era the early
Mainframe programming for business
transactions Banking and many more was
handled by COBOL since its veteran
programming language it had a tougher
verbose syntax with slow compilation and
deployment today with less than 0.5
percent of the developer Community COBOL
is considered one of the legendary
programming languages going extinct
that concludes our list of the top 10
dying programming languages for the year
2023 which of these programming
languages are the ones you like the most
and wish they stay for a while in the IT
industry let us know in the comments
section which one is your favorite
programming language and why hope you
enjoyed the video don't forget to like
this and share it with your friends and
subscribe to Simply learn to never miss
out on any updates thanks for watching
until next time stay safe and keep
learning
[Music]